herr kubicki wo waren sie gestern als
die kanzlerin das berühmte
video-statement vorgelesen hat oder sich
an die nation gewandt hat muss man ja
schon sagen und wie haben sie das
wahrgenommen
mich hat diego ich hab da kannst du ja
nicht erreicht es gibt keine
verpflichtung sich die wirtschaft der
kanzler anzuschauen weil wenn minister
steuer davon reden wir wollen nicht
wieder dass menschen zu hause bleiben
dass die alten in ihren pfleger 1
bleiben müssen dass kinder nicht zur
schule gehen können dann ist der appell
der kanzlerin nichts anderes als eine
verzweiflungstat sofort die menschen
jetzt zu einem freiwilligen doch dort
auf das heißt nicht mehr zu reisen nicht
mehr zusammen zu kommen zu hause zu
bleiben und das ein akt der
verzweifelung ich glaube schon dass wir
uns lösen müssen von diesen dauernden
teil zahlen weil sie zwar wichtig sind
weil ich alleine aussagekräftig sind
wichtig ist die frage wie dies mit
unserer intensivbetten aus mit
behandlungsmöglichkeiten sind weil eine
gefährdung des gesundheitssystems
meilenweit entfernt das tut nicht weh
dann früh doch jetzt droht das ist
unterstes überlastet wird insofern
sollten wir uns konzentrieren auch die
maßnahmen die wirklich sinnvoll sind und
nicht die bevölkerung in angst und
schrecken versetzt ja das ist auch
wirklich hat doch nicht wahr sein oder
wirklich mein kollege kubicki als
vizepräsident des deutschen bundestages
also ich habe ihn jetzt nicht setzen
sehen dass er einen alu helm aufhat
nicht so richtig gut aber trotzdem
lieber kollege kubicki es hier wirklich
verantwortung also wenn sie so eine so
einen wortschatz verwenden auch ihre
parteivorsitzende
alle müssen doch zusammen helfen mit
ihrer sicht in sotschi verrückt geworden
oder wie sich das würde ich bei allot
würde ich beim kollegen kubicki nie
sagen also verrückt geworden ist aber
trotzdem jeder hat eine verantwortung